[Music]  and there's several people here that's  been in our life our bodyguards two  bodyguards have been in our life that he  could go to and say hey can you come  bring a lot of me and he knows when his  seal that I would not say no he knows  that he knows had now Jennifer I don't  believe it  sugar if not one sugar please for once  be honest what ye I'm finna get on with  you right now  we'll split up it was every weekend  every every weekend I was up see Alana  and it was going good and you talking  about well we're gonna be busy this  weekend we're gonna be out of town but  I'll tell you what I got a lawyer on the  case you don't get the paperwork  paperwork for what Saul I gotta touch  I'm done  don't hey this is what happens this is  what happens  yo you Shannon what happened you stupid